right
good evening everybody welcome to rocha
district council's
remote meeting of the audit committee
and welcome to anybody who's watching
this for our live stream
our agenda item one tonight is apologies
for absence
we have one apology for absence and that
is
from mr councillor hoy
are there any others
no agenda item two substitute members
um i understand councillor wilson is
substituting for
um councillor high
agenda item three non-members attending
counsellor fd
thank you
agenda item 4 minutes of the meeting
held on the 29th of september
2020
are the minutes agreed members
agreed agreed
agreed
thank you agenda item
five to receive declarations of interest
are there any declarations of interest
[Applause]
no
agenda item six which is the redmond
review
naomi lucas the council's assistant
director of resources will introduce
this report
thank you naomi
thank you chair
um the purpose of this report is
to inform members of the conclusions and
recommendations arising from the
independent review into the oversight of
local audit and transparency of local
authority financial reporting
otherwise known as the redmond review
which is attached as an appendix
to the paper um this report has arisen
out of
um and inquired it was launched by the
secretary of state for the ministry of
housing communities and local
government in july last year
to support the transparency and quality
of local authority financial reporting
and external audits
the secretary of state appointed sir
tony redmond to conduct this review and
he was tasked with examining the
existing purpose
scope and quality of statutory audits of
local authorities in england and the
supporting regulatory framework
in order to determine whether it was
operating in line with policy intent
whether the introduction of the 2014
local audit and accountability act had
improved the effectiveness of the
control
and governance framework along with the
transparency of financial information
presented by councils
and thirdly the current statutory
framework for local authority financial
reporting
and whether that supported the
transparent disclosure of financial
performance
and enables users of the accounts to
hold local authorities to account
the report is summarized um in the com
in the covering reports um it is
fairly lengthy um in terms of the number
of
areas of exploration and um
recommendations
but um yeah the conclu conclusions and
proposals um
are summarized within that but i would
just like to draw members attention to a
couple of
key areas that particularly affect us as
a local authority
and so if i could refer members to
paragraph 4.10 at page 6.8
so this specifically refers to the
government's governance arrangements in
place for responding
to audit recommendations and there's
three recommendations
that um the redmond review has made to
local authorities
uh the first of which is that an annual
report should be submitted back to
full council by the external auditor
after
the accounts have been um considered by
audit committee
um whether or not those accounts have
actually been certified
um by that point in the year and
secondly
to give consideration to the
appointments of at least one independent
member who is suitably qualified to the
audit committee
and thirdly to put in place a facility
for
the chief executive officer the
monitoring officer
and the chief financial officer to meet
with the key audit partner
at least annually and that to make
that's a formal requirement
so um in terms of
the recommendations of this report um
which will be put forward to you
shortly i would just like to s um
inform members that we're recommending
that this audit committee should refer
um i a report of the annual accounts
back to full council each year
um obviously full council has delegated
the
um approval of the accounts to the audit
committee so that that that
um delegation would still stand it would
essentially be
um reporting back the findings and
outcomes of the audit
to council so that they're fully um
aware and it's fully transparent to all
members
um the second um
points about um appointing potentially
an independent
um member to the committee um
welcome to have a discussion and debate
about at this meeting but i think we're
proposing that we might bring something
further back to
a future meeting on that one um so maybe
we'll return to that point
and and the third recommendation about
um
the chief officers meeting with the
audit representative each year
that's that is already actually in place
and and that already happens so we're
compliant with that
um before we actually move to the
recommendations and any discussion
around those i would just like also to
say that
um the recommendations of the review are
um basically good practice but they're
not actually um formally
statutorily required at this at this
point it may be that
um some of the recommendations do
actually be um
formalized and and brought into the
statute book but at the moment it's
voluntary
um in terms of whether we choose to
adopt these recommendations
um but i would just say to members that
several um
other councils are choosing to implement
some of these recommendations
voluntarily
um so it it's something that um i'd
advise members to give some serious
consideration
to in line with best practice um
obviously there is a number of other
recommendations that are a bit broader
within the report so again if anyone's
got any particular
questions on any of those i can try and
answer them
as best i can so um i think that's all
i'll say at this point um
and yeah i'll try pass back to the chair
thank you
are there any questions uh by naomi
no yeah yeah sorry i have got my hand up
uh chairman yeah i mean having read this
report with great interest this just
seems to me
that we were already doing everything
that the government asked us to do
we ticked all the boxes they've just
done a review of their own procedures
and that basically are updating it or am
i missing missing the point here
um if i may come back chairs yes please
thanks thank you chair um so i think
that yeah the findings are quite
broad ranging as i i said i think in
terms of um
where the local authorities have adopted
them obviously there will be some
variability
across different local authorities as
you say i think a number of the points
we are already compliant with but that
might not be the case across all
local authorities but i think the
broader um
intention of the report is to actually
examine the um
sustainability and the effectiveness of
external audit firms and actually the
viability of the audit market
i think all members um who've been on
this committee before
will know that we've discussed um at
length previously that
um obviously the external audit firms
are struggling with resource and that
has impacted on the ability to meet
deadlines in terms of signing off the
annual accounts and there's also been
some bearing in terms of the fees and
the sustainability of the fee levels
so i think what this report is trying to
recommend is um
proposals that will increase the
stability and the sustainability of the
audit market
and mean that there's greater certainty
around
the annual accounts process each year
for authorities which
i think in broad terms we would um
support support those those findings
because um
as i say there has been some issues in
terms of uh being able to get our
accounts
and signed off by the deadline last year
for example and i think that's only
going to continue
into the future
jim can i just come back on that yes
thanks now i mean i i agree with you
know what what you're saying but
going from what you know having seen
this over the years
all we've had to do is do what the
government asked us to do
they were the ones that dictated who the
auditor should be how it was processed
all the fees that were set i mean this
is this was all stuff outside
our remit as far as i'm aware unless
i've got it badly wrong
but you know we've we've done everything
that's been asked of us and now we've
got to go
jump through some more hoops
yeah i think it was interesting to note
um
when i uh went into the webinar and
listened in that
40 of the um councils
hadn't um completed their accounts
in the year 1819 and it was getting
worse after that so i think we've done
really well
to have our accounts um in on time each
year
i know we struggled last year a bit but
um
you know we did get ours in so
there is a number of uh councils
struggling
throughout the country
any further questions
chairman councillor lucas gill has a
question councillor
lucas girl thank you chair
just a bit of an aside from what naomi
has just said
um i've
got the feeling that this is going to
massively increase
the fees that we as accountable have to
pay
auditors um because let's face it they
haven't done a very good job uh
time wise certainly but also i've
noticed in the financial pages
ey are in trouble again with
uh work that they've done for other
companies
um if i may come back just on the point
of
fee levels um i think again as we've
discussed previously the sustainability
of fee levels has been a particular
issue and
and the the redmond review itself and
anticipates that there may be fee
increases
around 25 percent um going forward in
order to maintain
um you know a functioning audit sector
um i think as we've
ourselves have experienced although the
fee levels were
set significantly lower when um
the um audit um the external
audit function was essentially
outsourced from the audit commission
that um
since then although the base fees have
been set um fairly low
we have experienced um additional fees
on top of that each year so
i think to some extent we are already
experiencing those increases in fees
it's just not in a transparent and sort
of sustainable way
so again while obviously um we want to
ensure we're getting value for money out
of the audit services
that we um receive in some ways
um i do support the idea that it would
be better that those fees are more
transparent and upfront
in the first place rather than them sort
of being added on as additional fees
each year
um which obviously makes it harder to to
budget and to know what those fees are
going to be going forward
thank you naomi
any further questions can i just come up
i mean have we are we still obliged to
to operate with this small select bank
that the the government tell us we can
choose from
um so again chair um
if i may uh so we as i am i think i've
probably
um said in previous meetings that we've
opted in via the um public sector
um auditor appointments um process to
actually um be part of a kind of
collective procurement which means that
we are um
essentially given an auditor each each
year
um it is possible to opt outside of that
process
and um appoint your own auditor um
having said that i think
the fee levels um where we to procure
that ourselves were again likely to be
higher than than those
if they're procured collectively and
secondly there's just not really an
active market
and um to actually go in a point
externally and
in actual facts uh many of the big audit
firms are trying to step back from
public sector audit work because it it's
not sustainable for them so
i think on both counts although it's
feasibly possible
it's probably not going to deliver any
better service or
or better price for us as a council
okay chair i'll put my hand up it's
councillor lauren shaw
this is nice yeah in in the corporate
world but i think you've just asked it
really
you can negotiate a fee with the auditor
can't we do this
um in public sector i know we've got to
have these auditors but can't we
actually negotiate a fee
so we know what an upfront fee we're
paying
um thank you councillor shaw again i
think i'd probably refer back to my
previous point and it is feasible but
obviously there is some
external factors which determine um both
the amounts
of work that's required and and the
price associated with that
so um even if we were to opt out of the
kind of joint procurement process
via psa and appoint our own auditor
we could perhaps negotiate a price um
but i'm not
convinced it would be any better value
for money for
the council and second as i said i think
it would be just
difficult to find anyone that that's
particularly interested in auditing a
small
um local on local authority just because
of
um the amounts and complexity of work
that's involved particularly
um these days as more and more um
sort of requirements get added each year
means that it's just not really an
attractive proposition for a lot of the
the the audit firms to actually come and
do the work
yeah can i come back sorry you missed my
point i know we've got to have
the auditors we've got i can understand
that
but with the orders as we must have that
the government
said can't we negotiate a fee
with them not go out and look for other
auditors
the auditors that we've got can we not
earn this neon can't we just say well
we want to what is the fee you're going
to charge us can't we negotiate that up
front
so then we know exactly what we're about
you've got a budget for
yeah thank you councillor sorry i
apologize i slightly missed your
your point before um so in terms of how
we agree the features so
at the end at the beginning of each
three year um
kind of procurement process there's
basically a base level fee that is set
so um that was all that was actually
negotiated a couple of years ago now
before the start of the the new
contract um but but they
um effectively can't price in all of the
unknowns and
the risks and so particularly to give an
example of the
covid related situation this year where
there's additional
um significant additional work that the
auditors will have to perform
to in light of all the covid risks that
they couldn't necessarily
have um anticipated that when they set
the base level
fee um and i think the other point that
we have had negotiations or
sort of discussions with the auditors
about is um
yeah the extra levels of regulations and
um
sort of changes to the audit um and
accounting standards
each year which again some of the things
around pensions for example
couldn't have been foreseen when they
set the original fees so
um i'm not here to defend the audit
firms but i think in fairness that they
do have to perform a significant amount
of additional work that they wouldn't
necessarily have known when they set the
original
contract and that's the point where we
do have discussions and negotiate to
some degree each year what the
appropriate fee level is
and i think the point of this wider
report is that um
i think it recognizes that across the
sector regardless of what each
individual authority's individual
situation is
it's just not sustainable as a as a
sector at the moment
and the danger is that if all the big
audit firms pull out
there just won't be anyone available to
actually do the work at all across the
whole of the sector so i think we have
to
perhaps just recognize a little bit
wider than just outside rockford that
that something's probably got to change
thank you naomi
thank you i don't see anybody else with
any further questions
so members at paragraph 9.1
on pages 6.9 and 6.10
there are four recommendations
recommendation one and four are for
noting
number one is that the report and the
three recommendations to local
authorities be noted
and number four that it be noted that
the chief executive officer
the monitoring officer and the chief
financial officer currently have the
facility to meet
with the key audit partner at least
annually
is that noted members noted
out of germany
all right thank you members turning to
recommendation
two i support the principal of the
committee providing an annual report to
council on the accounts
i would therefore like to move the
following recommendations
that the audit committee provides an
annual report to council on the accounts
as soon as possible after the audit
committee has considered them
do i have a secondar
thank you right voting will be done by a
roll call of names
when sonja calls out your name please
indicate if you wish to have a recorded
vote
and then whether you are voting for or
against the recommendation
or if you wish to abstain
uh so counselor mrs butcher
uh don't want to recall your vote and
for the recommendation
no recorded vote and four
councillor lucas gill no and four
councillor merrick
councillor milne no recorded vote and
for the recommendation counsellor
newport
no one for counsellor mrs shaw
no and four thank you counselor mr shaw
no and four thank you councillor sparing
no and for councillor wilson
no and for that's unanimously approved
chairman
all right thank you so that has been
carried
right recommendation three
that the recommendation to appoint at
least one independent member
suitably qualified to the audit
committee be considered
members i feel more detailed information
is needed on how this might work in
principle before filming a view on this
i would suggest asking officers to come
back to the committee with a role
profile
for an independent person and details of
appropriate allowance
and how that role will fit in with the
current aldi audit committee
i would therefore like to move the
following recommendation
that a report on the proposed
independent personnel be brought back to
the next meeting of the committee for
consideration
do i have a seconder for that i'll
second
thank you again voting will be done by a
roll call of names
when sonya calls out your name please
indicate if you wish to have a recorded
vote
and then whether you are voting for or
against the recommendation
or if you wish to abstain
counselor mrs butcher no recorded vote
and four councillor mrs carter
thank you no and four
councillor yuanu and nara recorded verge
and four
cancer lucas gill no and four
cancelameric
cancer sparing no and four
and councillor wilson no and
four unanimous chairman
thank you so that has been carried
so we now turn to an agenda item seven
local code of corporate governance
angela law assistant director of legal
and democratic will introduce the report
angela sorry thank you chairman um
just thank you members
the local code of corporate governance
was first adopted
um in 2017 in line with the framework
and the guidance issued by
sipha the code itself is not a legal
obligation however it is adopted by many
local authorities as a matter of good
guidance
and good guidance and practice the code
has recently been reviewed and
it has been updated um to align with the
council's business plan
and it will assist with the in the
completion of the annual government
statement
the to assist members the
seven core principles remain the same um
and the main changes in the document can
be seen
on pages 7.8 to 7.9 where we have
added the council's business plan and
from pages 7.10 onwards the core
principles remain the same but the
subprinciples
have been amended with clear reference
to the council's business plan
and then and reference to what the
objectives are under that
thank you chair
thank you are there any questions
no further questions
right paragraph 7.1 on page 7.2
there's one recommendation that the
local code of corporate governance be
agreed
again voting will be done by roll call
of names
when sonia calls out your name please
indicate if you wish to have a recorded
vote
and then whether you are voting for or
against the recommendation
or if you wish to abstain
counsel mrs butcher no recording vote
and four councillor mrs carter
thank you no recorded vote
councillor yuanu and i recorded vote and
four
councillor lucas girl no and four
councillor merrick
councilman milner
that's the mill you're unmute
so i pushed the bar on it on mu some
reason
um yeah no recorded votes and four
councillor newport no
[Music]
wilson no and for
that's unanimous chairman thank you for
that
has been carried we now turn
to agenda item eight audit progress
report 2020-21
mike porter our chief audit executive
will introduce the report
thank you chair i can ask members to
refer to section 1 of my report
as stated and since my last progress
report in july
the we have completed the further two
award engagements from the audit plan
um the one we rate is adequate assurance
relates to a review of the council's
elections process
in terms of the income and expenses that
claim for that
um the other piece of work where no
assessments awarded
relates to work we undertake in relation
to the housing benefits subsidy claim
this is work that we undertake on behalf
of the external auditor
so what we do is undertake a check of a
sample of housing benefit claims
to confirm their accuracy and
completeness and this is a piece of work
that
jim undertakes on behalf of the external
author
our work and the results of our work and
then inform
the further work undertaken by the
external auditor
and this basically results in a reduced
audit fee so we actually undertake work
on their behalf
they rely on our results and then it re
it directs their further work um
and the findings in relation to these
pieces of work can be
further analyzed or seen appending
through an appendix three to my report
um if i can now move on to changes to
the audit plan
um back in um july i mentioned that 2021
wouldn't be a normal year
because of covid and that the audit plan
would be subject to revision
mainly because of a result of um audit
resources being redirected elsewhere
um also the change in risk environment
so there'd be changes to the risk
environment new emerging risk would come
on board
so our audit plan would need to be
changed to reflect these new emerging
risks
um the revised audit plan is provided
from members at enclosure too
and at enclosure 2 we are providing
comments in terms of the audit
and a scope of the audit what it will
now look like under covered 19
and those audits we will no longer
undertake there are
five audits that we are proposing will
be deferred now and to the following
year
and these are because those all the
areas we wish to now audit
can't be ordered because they haven't
progressed as far as we would like so we
can't actually do an audit on those
areas because
um resources or management resources
have been directed elsewhere so those
audit areas can't be conducted at this
moment in time
and also there's those areas we no
longer want to um
visit at this moment in time because of
the changing or
emerging new risks so as i said
the revised plan is provided at
enclosure too
if i can now move on to section two of
my report
and this deals with um counter fraud
activity
as members may be aware that um i went
to covered and to support local
businesses
um business grants have been payable to
a number of businesses
in the rockford area and this is part of
an application process
so businesses can actually fill in an
application and apply for these various
respective grants
um what we have done as an audit team
and and
what is required by central government
is to look at these payments and confirm
they are
have been eligible for payment and
there's no fraud that basically
businesses that didn't exist have made
the claim so what we're trying to do is
check that
every business that has been awarded the
grant does exist or did exist
as that march and what's on the basic
council tax database
so this is a piece of work that jin's
been looking at to inform
or confirm that the payments we have
made by rochford
are accurate and eligible
um also in terms of basically fraud
activity
the rebs and benz team performed
compliance functions
and they have achieved a significant
cashable savings over the period
april to september of this year in a
region of 77
77 000 pounds so what what they have
identified
is properties that have been unbilled in
terms of council tax
and where discounts has been claimed
with exemptions that no longer apply
um lastly if i can ask members to refer
to section 3 of my report
and these and this deals with um audit
recommendations
what we have seen is that we only have a
basically a limited number of live
recommendations
effectively there are only 13 live
recommendations at this moment in time
and what we have seen is a push back and
forth those by
service managers and that's quite
understandable during cobin 19 is that
these these management that their
priorities have changed
and they're basically activities have
been directed elsewhere so basically
those there's four audit recommendations
which have been pushed back
in terms of um implementation dates and
that
accept the books we understand um
offices time has changed and
priorities have changed um since since
the um the last progress
we've only um introduced two new audit
recommendations
i'm quite happy to take any questions
councillor sparing
thank you chairman i appreciate what
what mike said i mean
we've been hearing him for a number of
years now
taking all these items
in isolation fine but
when we take them on block is this
creating
a substantial increase in the workload
for the accounts section and
will we be able to maintain i appreciate
what mike said where he said about some
of them
not meeting or being held back are we
going to be
able to comply with all the new bits and
pieces that we're signing up for
i mean we don't want to go back down the
road where we were a few years ago
um you know we we've made great headway
over the last couple of years
and you know i don't want us to find
that
we're we're going back where we once
were thank you chairman
um i'm sorry i'm not sure i sort of
understand the question i mean
i mean basically taking all these into
account
have we got the resources to deal with
all the bits and pieces that we're now
being asked to
address that's the long and short of it
right sorry yes um
yeah in terms of the um audit resources
um
what we have available um baseline
council who are who i work for so we can
call on resources from
and council what i can assure members is
the revised audit plan will be completed
in its entirety so basically we do have
the resources to complete the plan
and the plan will mainly enable myself
to give an opinion at year end so
basically
sufficient work will still be completed
we have the resources to undertake the
revised audit plan
um why we revise it is that there are
particular audits
that we can no longer undertake because
they haven't been
progressed so there's nothing to
actually audit in those areas we haven't
come as far as we'd like to
so we can't give an opinion on those
areas because we haven't been
we haven't sufficiently progressed those
areas of work
but in terms of all the other areas that
are actually in the revised plan yes
we've got sufficient resources and
rockford council can also call upon
passing the council my own council to um
deliver parts of the plan
and that is what will happen this year
so yeah
thanks mike appreciate it thank you it's
reassuring
councillor lucas girl thank you chair
uh mike um there have been so many
fraudulent
claims throughout the country for
millions of pounds of
money uh is there much evidence of any
in rockford and how much time is this
taking you
um i mean i could pass over over to jim
for this piece
um but from my examination the work
jim's undertaking there's no real
evidence of fraud in relation to the
payments we have made
yes there is widespread fraud but like a
number of councils
um rochard also well introduced an
application process so basically
businesses had one initially had to
apply for the grant
and this allowed us to undertake some
initial checks to confirm they
did exist were legitimate businesses and
then on top of that
um jim's come in to sample checker a
number of the payments
to confirm the checks we actually
undertook so there's a double check so
revs and benz have done their own
checking to confirm
whether these businesses are legitimate
or not and now we're coming in to double
check that to make sure actually
the processes were adequate
and fit for purpose and that's where
jim's come in to check a sample of those
payments
but from from the initial work we're not
seeing widespread evidence of fraud
in rocha but um jim do you have anything
to add
um no i think the uh the revenues and
benefits team have
uh bonding to the anti-fraud elements of
it in a
bit of gusto uh i would which i would
expect he also knows that thing
um but they have identified a couple of
fortunate cases and did pass them on to
the department for a
industry um they've taken on a
taking on a big big thing about the team
uh gone into it very conscientiously
and i've not had any evidence of any
fraud within the revenues benefits items
i looked at
um similarly the uh enviro
economic development team have been
processing the discretionary grants
again from my sample that work still has
some queries outstanding just for sort
of uh clarification
but there's no certainly no evidence
i've seen a fraud in there
thank you okay thank you very much
there doesn't appear to be any further
questions
so at paragraph 7.1
on page 8.2 there are three
recommendations
number one that the update on delivering
the 2021 audit plan be noted
number two that the conclusions and
results from completed audit engagements
in appendices one and two be noted
and number three that the updated status
of audit recommendations in appendix
four be noted
are they noted members
yes no dude
all right thank you so we now
go on to agenda item nine which is the
review of the council's risk register
for 2021
naomi lucas assistant director will
introduce the report
naomi please
thank you chair
so members of the committee will be
aware that we consider the risk register
twice
a year and generally we consider half
the risks
in the first six months of the year and
the other half in the second six months
of the year
um in light of the um
significant risks particularly around
the covered situation
um we took the decision um earlier in
the year in july to actually do a full
review of the risk register
and we brought that back as i say to the
july committee
um at which time um we'd reviewed each
of the risks individually and
made any appropriate amendments um in
light of
covid and other emerging risks
so um for this time we have reverted
back
to the um normal pattern and we've
reviewed half of the
the risks and the other half will be
brought back to a subsequent audit
committee
um in light of that there have been some
minor changes
um around some of the wording of the
control measures in place
um but there's been no major changes
either in terms of the risks reported
or the um the the scoring of the risks
in terms of their
their likelihood um and their impacts
um we did take on board some comments at
the last audit committee about
um risks which have a high residual risk
rating
um even after control measures are
implemented and in particular
last time we spoke about the risk of
setting a balanced budget
which is risk number nine and risk
number 10 which is the inability to
recruit and retain
offices across the council in addition
as one further risk health and safety
which remains high
which we have spoken about in some
detail at previous committee meetings
so we have um expanded on the
rationale behind the the risk ratings
for those in the report at
paragraphs um 5.1
to 5.4 um and in addition at
um section 6 we've noted the um
emerging issue of the um of britain's um
leaving the eu um obviously at the end
of this year and the fact that that may
have some
impacts on um the the risks within the
risk register we haven't got a specific
risk around
that because we are actually developing
a specific risk register
and brexit specifically um
in addition we have also noted at
section seven the potential area of
consideration around
um the evolution and recovery white
paper which has been
um deferred now um probably until summer
of next
year which could obviously have a
significant impact on the way local
authorities are
organized in the future
um so yes i'm happy to answer any
particular questions
members may have on the risk register
um and yeah the
um recommendations i believe are just
um for noting that noting the risk
graduate step
risk register itself thank you
so i can't see anybody wanting any
questions
um does anybody want to ask a question
no so a paragraph 13.1 on page 9.4
there's one recommendation that the
content of the corporate risk register
for 2021 be noted
is that noted members noted
noted
well thank you very much everybody
we had a bit of a difficult start
but uh that concludes the meeting for
today
thank you all for attending and for your
contribution in the meeting and i now
declare the meeting closed
at 8 15 pm